oh my god I'm so hungover I have like
four tasks
I have to write like ten papers my else
hats coming out in 14 months
adderall highly barely studying for that
test but I got an a I took like 32 shots
last night I'm never drinking again you
might hit Froyo are you lived in that
dorm for every year what textbooks cost
me $300 the only thing I can afford is
ramen Europe is like life-changing like
cantering American coffee anymore you
just wouldn't understand if you weren't
there I'm pretty much bilingual sorry
bud rat capacity dirty girls the right
person will come when you least expect
it I want to bang as many girls as I can
before I graduate do you even have a job
yeah you go to the Career Fair
yeah I'm majoring in finance English
major you gonna do with that so uh I'm
actually making some money when I
graduate has anyone told you the
importance of networking by the way my
boyfriend's getting in tonight he's
gonna stay with us for a few weeks hope
that's chill
[Music]